can you tell the story of this
recent uh controversy sure sermon you
just gave you
the super bowl yeah i think a lot of
people would relate to this because to
me personally i apologize to anybody who
was hurt by this the absurdity of it is
deeply intense so here's the story the
la county mandates masking children in
school and all of kids in our school are
masked and many of the parents are
extremely upset about that
i will just leave that at that yeah um
i went to the super bowl
there were 70 thousand people
frank luntz whom we know was a wonderful
guy he gave me a ticket um
sir and so i was at the super bowl and i
did i maybe saw two masks among the 70
000 people i didn't even think about it
which was foolish on my part no question
i took a picture of myself unmasked at
the super bowl
and
people were
i mean many many people thought oh great
wonderful glad you're having a good time
so and so but i don't want to diminish
at all the many people who said that a
lot of people were livid they were livid
and they weren't
um
what was what was instructive about it
was they didn't say
nobody wrote me a private note and said
you know i think that this was a bad
idea you should have thought about this
no
they were you're a hypocrite you're a
clown you're an idiot how could you do
this this is a disgrace this is
that i say that publicly oh yeah on on
on my instagram you can still see i left
the remarks up because i really thought
it was important if i started i only
deleted the really vile comments um
because i thought that shouldn't stay up
but i left them up because i thought
like people should see
and i should remind myself what i did
and i didn't want to just delete the
picture as though it didn't happen
because it did happen and i did do it
and i felt terrible about that and i
felt terrible that i had not not about i
mean the comments believe me weren't
weren't pleasant i didn't like it um
nobody likes it but i felt worse that i
had hurt all these people that i'm close
to and i defended all these people who
were really upset that their kids were
wearing masks and now they their kid
says why doesn't the rabbi have to wear
a mask well first of all it is tough to
be a rabbi
i mean uh
the masks to me symbolize these kinds of
discussions symbolize
not necessarily the issues at hand but
the intensity of feeling and people are
really struggling people are in pain
they're lonely
they're the uncertainty of it you don't
know who to trust everything's under
question the institutions even the
scientific institutions and there's all
these
conspiracy theories flying around you
don't know who to believe and there's
people just yelling at each other and
politics is weaved into this whole thing
in some messy way and you're just
getting i mean honestly it's just like
legit simple
just frustration
going back to marriage of just hanging
out
with
the kids and your wife husband just
distressed just building up over time no
release and just people want to tell you
when the rabbi is not wearing a mask
even though it's at the damn super bowl
maybe you want to comment on the super
bowl part which is awesome but anyway
but it released clearly a dam of all the
kinds of feelings that you're talking
about so how do you then write a sermon
so i well so what i did was i didn't
answer on social media because i knew
that i wouldn't be able to formulate it
the way i wanted and i was going to wait
and i was going to be able to give a
longer i mean the sermon is 15 minutes
not that long but i wanted to be able to
give a longer answer as opposed to
a tweet
and so
i was really i mean
i tried to make two points during the
sermon and i and also i published the
text of it which i never do because i
never speak from a text i always speak
from either notes or not even from notes
but this time i thought it was really
important that i have a text out there
too so that people could actually look
over it um
and
and i just wanted to make two points one
of which was that i really feel terrible
and i did that i all these people were
hurt and that there is this you know
contradiction between the way i acted
and the way they want me to act and i
also think by the way i didn't speak
about this but i also think that there
are some people who just don't like the
idea of a rabbi being at the super bowl
it's like you're supposed to be doing
rabbi stuff so i understand that too
but then
yeah so but you know rabbi at the super
bowl i mean you're also
i i'd hate to say it but there's there's
a rockstar nature to you talking to
christopher hitchens contending with
ideas inspiring so many other minds i
mean there's an educational aspect i
appreciate that it's making ideas cool i
mean that's a very powerful that i mean
that is also the job of a rabbi you're
not just supposed to do rabbi stuff yeah
yeah yeah but i didn't do so much of
that you know
at the game so um i see
nonetheless so
but the second part of it was i said
that we have to be able
to express our anger and disappointment
better than this
you just have to
i'm in part because it doesn't
get you the result that you want i mean
when you scream at someone that's not
going to get them to realize what they
did
and
and the
the most painful
um moment of it was this letter that i
got from a christian pastor who said you
know i always admired the jews so much i
can't believe they could be so cruel and
especially to a rabbi and i thought
that's not how i want my congregation to
be perceived in the world
and by the way some of them were from my
congregation some were
uh many were not from my congregation
but
um
but and and i spoke about what you
talked about which is that
uh you know i mentioned before that
moses broke those tablets coming down
the mountain and the torah doesn't say
what happened to the tablets but the
rabbis do they say that they were
carried together in the ark with the
second set that was intact and that we
all have brokenness communities and
individuals we have brokenness and
especially now
and we have to learn how to give each
other space to be mistaken and broken
and hurt and all of that um and the cool
thing when you give people that space
you you feel better i mean you for
caring for the community
it feels better
when you show empathy and compassion and
kindness on the internet you'll actually
feel better a week from now you'll feel
much worse
if you make some kind of uh negative
statement
of principle on the internet it's almost
just
exclusively true so if you care about
feeling good just be kind first right be
empathetic first almost always the case
exactly so um so it's uh
i mean it it settled down a lot um the
most really the single
best reaction i there were there are
people
and you can again you can go on social
media you can see all the criticisms and
so on and so forth um but the single
best reaction i got was from a man who
came up to me right after the sermon
um
and said i have four words for you and i
thought oh no
i
i said i said what he said you changed
my mind
and i thought wow and i said to him you
know that's so
it's like to take so much courage to
come up to somebody and say that in
front of them and i was so grateful
and
the other thing that it tells me is look
i've been the rabbi of that congregation
for 25 years and i taught 10 years
before that i've been a rabbi for a long
time i still i still have a lot to learn
you